do you know what I'm thankful for this
Thanksgiving you who keep supporting us
I'd make out with you m if it wasn't
illegal and considered prostitution you
keeping this struggling ass Channel
alive I love you so let me hook you up
this Black Friday now till the 28th 25%
off on special selections and free
stickers and pen for every order I don't
even know why we got so many damn people
on the payroll but I'm about to do
another 40% pay cut on these Free
Loaders so I could pass on the savings
to you so this Black Friday feed your
favorite influencers merchlabs
docomo jk- newws man we need a new URL
that is not easy to say thank you very
much